retired army general h.r mcmaster was
president trump's national security
advisor in 2017 and 2018. before that he
served in afghanistan as a senior
military commander general good morning
good morning good morning anthony good
to be with you is it your belief general
that we should not have left afghanistan
absolutely and i think you can just see
that based on on the tragedy that's
unfolding before our eyes and of course
we're seeing a humanitarian catastrophe
anthony but it's worse than that it's a
it's going to affect our security it's
going to affect our reputation in the
world and it's going to strengthen the
jihadist terrorists who we went to
afghanistan to defeat after the most
devastating terrorist attack in history
on september 11
2001. general if you go back for through
three presidencies they all wanted to
leave afghanistan the american public
does not support us being there but you
say
we talked ourselves into defeat in
afghanistan what do you mean
well i'll tell you anthony we've had
three presidents in a row tell us it is
not worth it but i think what we're
seeing today is that the cost of our
precipitous withdrawal far exceeds
the cost of a sustained and sustainable
commitment there i mean anthony we had i
mean who knows what the number would be
you know 8 500 3500 troops but what was
important about the
beyond the numbers is that afghans were
bearing the brunt of their fight right
to preserve the freedoms that they've
enjoyed
since we helped them defeat the taliban
in 2001 but they were also fighting for
us for all humanity on a modern day
frontier between barbarism and
civilization against jihadist terrorists
who are the enemies of all humanity are
you are you suggesting that we should we
should effectively have a permanent
force in afghanistan is that your belief
well i mean i'll tell you anthony are we
still in south korea right we have 30
000 troops in south korea we had you
know we had 3 500 2500 troops most
recently
in afghanistan who as i said were
enabling the afghans to bear the brunt
of the fight against our common enemies
and the cost of that was minuscule and
it was sustainable look at the cost now
to the afghan people to the world to
humanity and what was it worth it right
we can we can cry all the crocodile
tears we want anthony about you know
afghan women but if they don't have the
security
to prevent you know these criminals
these these uh these jihadist terrorists
use a perverted interpretation of of
islam uh to you know to justify their
criminal acts uh then then what do you
what can you do you can't do anything
without that kind of fundamental
security but general i mean if you look
at south korea i mean in korea
the people in control there want us
there
the difference in in afghanistan is that
there's a large element of the country
that doesn't
you did you see the images of people
running you know again next to that c-17
aircraft did they do they want us there
or do they want the taliban there i
think this is really a false narrative
we did everything we could to deliver
psychological blows to the afghan
government and the armed forces on our
way out right we began to negotiate with
these criminals in in in gutter without
the afghan government what did that do
for the for the legitimacy of the afghan
government we made concession after
concession we forced them to release 5
000 of the most heinous people on earth
who returned immediately to the
battlefield and began to again victimize
the afghan people i mean i don't know do
you think the afghan people are
welcoming the taliban under these
conditions i don't think so many of them
have accommodated with them because why
they looked over their shoulders and
said who's got our back and we said not
us we're leaving but a lot of americans
would look at this general and say we
spent 20 we spent 20 years there
billions of dollars trying to build up
their army which collapsed in a matter
of days
okay anthony you know we withdrew 2500
troops how many are there now right so
wars don't end when one party decides to
disengage the taliban al-qaeda which is
completely intertwined
with the taliban didn't say oh hey the
americans aren't here anymore let's just
stop the jihad so we have our own
narrative our narcissistic
self-referential narrative about ending
the endless wars but hey guess what wars
don't end when we leave and our enemies
are fighting an endless jihad
it certainly is a scary situation there
right now general mcmaster thank you so
much for being with us this morning we
do appreciate it
thank you anthony